hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report Max Keiser named by the magazine
in The Spectator magazine in the United
Kingdom as one of the most annoying
thinks of 2019 that's right I'm on the
same list as Greta thorn Bork and a lot
of other stuff wow that's awesome
take that Joe Rogan Stacy yes you're one
of the 41 most annoying things about
2019 according to Spectator magazine
they call you an excitable duck sounding
economist it kind of excitable ducks
voiced economist yes
let's quack on with these headlines
because of course the markets ended 2019
with partying like it's 1999
you know 1999 if you recall because you
were part of that dot-com thing well the
Nasdaq ended up 85 percent in 1999 it
ended up almost 40 percent in 2019 so
it's boom times again and we're gonna
look at some tweets here about the whole
2019 assessment 2019 just keeps getting
better and better than Nasdaq closed
above 9,000 for the first time ever and
is up almost 38% for the year that was
earlier in December before the end of
the year so we're still looking back at
that time you're making a comparison to
1999 years here you're indicating or
inferring bubble-like
qualities I would imagine and it does
look bubblicious it you know but these
are the rest of the world is in dire
straits other you know also think about
it the the Venezuelan stock market was
up spectacularly recently since you said
that I'm gonna jump ahead to some a few
another tweet here to indicate what
might be happening the rest of the world
might be in distress but the fact is the
US Federal Reserve Bank has been
printing enormous amounts of money and
it's going in lockstep with the increase
in the Nasdaq in the stock market
because remember from mid-september when
the repo market turmoil erupted the Fed
started printing money and in the last
two weeks of 2019
here we're in 2020 mid 2020 but they're
still printing the last two weeks of
2019 they printed four hundred and fifty
billion dollars their asset there their
balance sheet expanded by that so let's
look at that fed balance sheet moves up
to four point one six six trillion
highest level in 14 months up over four
hundred and six billion over the last
four months quote in no sense is this QE
this is nothing like it
Jerome Powell had said October 8 2019
you could see that it's a v-shaped
recovery and the Fed's balance sheet
since you know the Nasdaq as I said was
up 40% nearly 40% so 60% of the gain and
the Nasdaq happened from that point
let's revisit my ongoing theory which is
that you've got really low interest
rates now for ten years near zero or in
some case it's negative and there are a
few private equity folks that are taking
all the stock off the board you know and
remember in monopoly the winner has all
the real estate and everyone else
becomes Ron TA right so this is the same
thing Nasdaq is just a proxy for
monopoly and the players that are
winning this are both the bank and a
Park Avenue in Park Place the two most
valuable spots on the board game of
Monopoly so that's this is exactly what
we've been saying for a few years now if
you keep printing trillions and
trillions of dollars and you don't allow
it to go into wages you cut them off you
you you you vilify the working person
and you just give it to private equity
speculators you're gonna end up with
this enormous bifurcation in the economy
of extraordinarily wealthy plutocrats
and kleptocrats and sort the surf class
the losers the deplorable z-- I might
add that it's also hedge funds hedge
funds play a big part in the repo market
that's where they go for funding and
then 10x leveraged up into the markets
so that's important because of course as
I mentioned here's the Fed's balance
sheet it had been declining it was down
8% on the year at one point for the
first three quarters of 2019 it
the year up 2% to Fed's balance sheet so
that was a huge turnaround that's the
v-shaped recovery so I'll match that to
this tweet tear Fang Minh market cap has
hit fresh all-time high five point two
four nine trillion which is almost equal
to the combined GDP of France and UK as
big tech keeps rallying phangnan our
Facebook Apple Netflix and Google so if
you look at those chart that's the surge
and the Fed's balance sheet
I either printing money and that's the
surge and the fang minh shares out there
so it's they're going lockstep so to put
this in perspective they're on a global
basis there was never any diminishment
of money printing so the Fed was down
maybe six seven eight percent at one
point over a year over a year the trend
was extraordinarily expansive maybe a
couple of quarters down but globally
it's never going down and at any month
it's never gone down so the global
printing by all the globe's major
central banks has gone on on this
hyperbolic increased which has led to a
38 year bond market rally which is
unprecedented and unreasonable and is
dangerous for any economy to have that
kind of miss allocation and it trickles
down to the fang stocks and the fang
stocks are momentum stocks the you know
this this was an overvalued group five
years ago four years ago three years ago
two years ago one year ago one month ago
last week it'll be an overvalued group
in six months i can't get more
overvalued because the ratio of nasdaq
to S&P 500 was almost twice as high in
2000 during the.com bubble so those
valuations could continue to rise so
don't fight the Fed and don't fight
Warren Buffett I might add because
Warren Buffett might be even bigger than
the Fed remember he poured into Apple
early in 2019 well this is a tweet about
Apple the biggest largest company in the
world well I guess Aramco Saudi Aramco
is now the biggest but Apple is the
biggest corporation in America in case
you missed that Apple
it's up over 80% in 2019 as best year in
a decade largest traded company added
five hundred and thirty billion dollars
in market value this year more than the
market cap of all but five comparables
in SP 500 and twice the market value of
Intel so that's the price rise in Apple
in 2019 and of course right you know the
big loser bad was Carl Icahn you know
Carl Icahn was sold to Warren Buffett I
don't ride 140 I believe $150 of shares
sound close to 300 so it's a double
since Carl Icahn
and he sold it because he thought it was
overvalued the market was overvalued he
told everyone to get out of the market
he stopped managing private money he
only manages like this huge family
office fund so he's been dead wrong I
mean there's a multi billionaire who's
generally been right going back to the
80s he was part of the the Mike Milken
crowd of the 1980s who were given
extraordinarily huge tax breaks and free
money as you had the S&L crisis and then
the drexel burnham crisis but he's been
dead wrong you know with Apple Computer
it started off at a very low valuation
remember back in the late 90s when it
was at less than $10 a share adjusted
for splits Michael Dell at Dell computer
recommended that Steve Jobs quit the
computer business and that he was no
good at it and nobody wanted that to buy
the stock at under 20 bucks now
everybody wants to buy the stock at 1.3
trillion dollar valuation you know it's
that's a contrarian ISM versus the
blindingly obvious you know Warren
Buffett pursues the blindingly obvious
every a lot of people are like hedge
funds or contrarian and tend to
underperform even a simple Vanguard
type S&P tracking fund well we're gonna
look at a chart of Apple going back 39
years this is it right here is the
dot-com bubble that little tiny blip
down there this is the 2008 crash and as
you see it's gone hyperbolic since then
the Fed money printing has done well for
them I guess
also the powerful State Department
introducing in intellectual property
laws and thin
like that around the world has done well
but it's hard to see on this chart but
it's definitely going parabolic this
year based on that long-term 39 year
chart right you know going back to the
late 90s and early 2000s Apple was a
really hated company because it had lost
a lot of people a lot of money after the
heyday after it gone public and then
Steve Jobs left the company if you
recall and the stock was a
underperformer and people really hated
it so as a result you know Apple at just
now as on a price earnings multiple is
just now becoming closer to the market
average on a p/e ratio it's not
overextended like back in the dot-com
days you have these tech companies are
Nasdaq or Netflix for example or the
other Fang stocks are trading at 70 80
120 times earnings or 200 times earnings
astronomical price earnings multiple the
case of Apple they're just trading at a
market multiple I believe last I checked
it's somewhere around 20 up from you
know two years ago it was a 10 or 12
which is extraordinary
so you mentioned Carl Icahn and you
mentioned that he had said it was
overvalued and of course a lot of these
things are overvalued based on
historical metrics but history never had
negative interest rates they never had
such activists central banks I mean
central banks are pretty new and on a
global situation in the United States
line got ours in 1913 and of course Bank
of England has been around for a while
but we were on everybody was on a gold
standard back then so we haven't had
that sort of interventionist central
bank policy as we see now we're gonna
get into another chart about that in
another statement about central banks
but of course Warren Buffett also he
does have a metric the one metric he
looks at to determine whether or not
markets are in a bubble as he said if
market cap equals 100% of GDP that's
when he said he decides to sell and that
has happened in the last month of 2019
that happened I think it started out
December at like 85% and now it was like
surge so hard into de some into the end
of December that it hit 100% so here's a
tweet from Karl Kuhn tella Fed's balance
sheet continues as
EPIK rise up by an average of one
hundred and 1.5 billion dollars per
month since september compared to 80
billion per month during qe3
quote it's hard not to imagine this
influence on stock prices as long as
interest rates are near zero it doesn't
matter it could be twenty thirty
trillion dollars on the balance sheet
here's a thought experiment and a bit of
a prediction for 2020 going back to
Saudi Aramco Aramco as it went public
just recently at a market valuation in
excess of 1.5 trillion dollars I think
at one point was worth two trillion
dollars I think that we're gonna see
them make a hostile buy of a company
maybe a Facebook for example and it
could be the first trillion dollar
hostile raid in history because they've
got the balance sheet now if you've got
a two trillion dollar balance sheet that
means you've got you know the ability to
borrow another trillion so you've got a
three trillion dollar war chest if you
go after an apple or even a Berkshire
Hathaway at five or six hundred billion
dollars so why wouldn't Saudi Aramco by
Berkshire Hathaway just as a hostile
rate and then they own a like a huge
portion of the whole global market the
American market why not they've got the
balance sheet now they want to diversify
away from oil and gas and I think we're
gonna see a move like that in the next
six to nine months well I do believe
that we could see a doubling like we did
in the end of the parabolic move because
remember Alan Greenspan had warned that
the markets were displaying irrational
exuberance he said that in 97 we
continued on for two more years 1999 the
Nasdaq went up 85 percent we only went
up 40 percent in 2019 if this is a
exuberance and you know the retail
investor wasn't really participating in
29 everybody hated it everybody was like
dissing it even big names like Carl
Icahn everybody was out so this could be
the year that it's in and that ties to
this final headline Nobel laureate
economist praises Trump for stock market
rally he creates animal spirits Nobel
laureate for economics Robert Shiller
sees President Donald Trump as a primary
cause of Wall Street's recent strength
because he stoking the markets animal
spirits Shiller won the Nobel Prize in
2013 chillers newly-found praise for
trump is a huge turnaround
from the point of view he held back in
January of 2018 when he said in an
interview he would give Trump a grade of
1 or 2 out of 10 when it comes to
economic policy he said he didn't vote
for Trump in 2016 but he thinks he'll
win in 2020 right so Shiller agrees with
me and I've said for three years now
that Trump instills confidence in people
the American economy is 70% consumer and
you have that's a key component of
Barrack Obama never get no one it gave
anyone any confidence to do anything
everyone looked at Barrack Obama in his
presidency and his policies and they
were like I think I'll wait for somebody
like a Trump okay we're gonna take a
break and when we come back much more
coming your way welcome back to the
Kaiser a part time now to turn to Mitch
Firestein author of planet Ponzi calm
Mitch welcome back great to be here from
Bath in England so Mitch let's get into
this you know the markets are defying
all who we're looking for a pullback
these last two or three years we seem to
be heading to 30,000 on the Dow what's
going on I'll tell you max I'm pretty
I'm pretty surprised actually you know
we called it wrong this year I'm first
to admit it you know the Nasdaq is up
close to 40% this year what we have an
all-time highs for the decade we've got
stocks bonds property credit markets the
debt markets corporate debt stock
buybacks cielos valuations QE all at
all-time highs on central bank geneva
Latian and i think that that's the story
we also have the new lows which our
interest rates at historic 600 year lows
trust in our government trust in big
tech Facebook Twitter Google the
politicians media the government the FBI
NSA Congress all at new lows so the next
decade is gonna be a ripper we're gonna
see the next decade massive amounts of
opportunity that will make the 40
percent gain Nasdaq look small I think
we're talking about a
big correction that we'll see in the
distortions that the central banks have
put forward for the last ten years
during the next ten years 2020 is going
to be a real beginning of the next
decade of a turnaround for where markets
have been going on central bank magic
for the past ten years I guess we'd have
to make the comparison to 1999 I was
very involved in the dot-com era at that
time you were managing money you
observed it firsthand is it similar to
1999 you had the Nasdaq was up 80
something percent that year Alan
Greenspan had in 1996 a warned of
irrational exuberance it then went on to
catapult higher you had the IPOs that
were being launched at a 50 to 60%
first-day pop if you remember that was
the big thing I remember when I was at
the Hollywood Stock Exchange we were
about to go public at Bear Sterns and
Barbra Streisand was calling me asking
to get stuck in the IPO you know things
were crazy is it similar to 1999 I
think it's similar to 1990 not only
$19.99 for 1929 max I think the
valuations are in the stratosphere
valuations on a on the metric that Yale
University uses the Cape Mets they
probably never get higher or close to
all-time historic eyes when we have
didn't have 1999 are so many billion
dollar zombie corporations and we've
actually got a couple of trillion-dollar
unicorns and we've got trillion-dollar
unicorns that already come out of the
closet I mean we've got companies like
Amazon companies like Tesla you can go
and Apple the devaluations that are a
little bit ridiculous right now
but they keep rolling up because they
not to me which is 44 by the Fed the
Bank of Japan the European Central Bank
these guys have been buying equities the
Bank of Japan is buying on
hand-over-fist the Swiss National Bank
is buying equities hand over fist
me it's just a matter of time before the
feds start buying equities as well in my
belief I think that you will see more QE
I think they have no other chance but to
do key we need to keep these markets
buoyant they've created Frankenstein's
fly the Frankenstein's baby with these
markets and now will do anything to
defeat them in the stratosphere the
problem is this only wants until it
doesn't you know ain't really buck this
trend because it's a problem as it as
I've said for a couple years it's
impossible to pick the top of a bubble
and we can tell you're in a bubble right
now because nothing makes any sense
cheston's borrowed what thirteen billion
dollars to make their studio to make a
profit you can see a chart that we have
of Tesla and you see that this is an
all-time high
making the valuation of Tesla I think
the second largest auto company in the
world that they've only produced less
than half a million cars in their
existence it's not groundbreaking
everybody else in 2020 is coming out
with their new evey vehicles the big
technology in those vehicles is the
batteries and quite frankly it needs
unique rare earth metals so those metals
have to come from China I doubt the
Chinese building is very helpful in
promoting American companies over there
only TVs like BMW Porsche everybody's
getting into the game that we use now so
Tesla I think become a Harvard Business
School study and the rationale examines
type and I am a virtual virtue signaling
to the max that invest everything in the
Tesla drive my Tesla which is not even
in this case it was the Millennials who
are on there Robin Hood stock app that
were right they've been buying Tesla for
the last three or four years and the
stock just made a new all-time high the
professionals were shorting it and now
there's this huge short squeeze let me
ask you kind of a thought exercise here
because in an era now where the rumor is
that Blackrock and Blackstone are going
to merge to create a multi trillion
bowel or financial behemoth and you've
got Aramco Saudi Aramco went public it's
now got you know one point
two trillion dollar valuation my here's
my thought exercise is it possible that
Aramco could do a hostile raid of a
company like a Facebook and and at a
trillion dollar take out well we see
potentially the first trillion dollar
deal as a hostile deal is that is that a
possibility you know if they want to
diversify why not
Mitch look I think I rent that Aramco
trade as and saw the stock dropped
precipitously after the IPL I was very
skeptical about the valuation in that
IPL as I was very skeptical about me
works valuation at 5757 billion I think
I said at the time last January I said
we work as a Ponzi scheme we work turned
out to be a Ponzi scheme those guys are
getting huge payouts now I don't know
why it took down soft banks vision Fund
going back to your scenario with a
trillion dollar buyout I don't think
that's gonna happen that I think you see
I think we had a another oil company
years ago email is such a wild valuation
and they turned out to about a hundred
billion dollars after opening up with a
trillion or something and look I think
these are ridiculous valuations
especially with a lack of transparency
in a ramp tones financial documentation
I think people are chasing you and
there's all these central banks that
push yields to negative I mean we've got
a universe of 17 trillion dollars in
negative nearly debt now when I started
on Wall Street in 1980s you know it
never guaranteeing that what I can't
guarantee you is if you buy one of these
negative yoku bonds we were definitely
and hold it to maturity or definitely
lose money you know gotta change what
are these covenants and the pension
funds because they should not be allowed
to buy any instrument that you're
guaranteed to lock a loss for the
pensioners and this is just exploitation
and it's schooling from savers burden
savers to bail out banks or backdoor
bailouts and we've talked about many a
time and you know this is gonna come
full circle in the next
all this is gonna blow up and it's not
gonna end well I think what's happening
is this is a diversion away from bad
news around the world
you received a civil unrest that's
spawned in Paris in Hong Kong and Spain
all over the world you're seeing civil
unrest and this has to do with the
greatest wealth inequality the central
bank actions have precipitated by
lowering interest rates and pumping
hundreds of trillions of dollars into
the credit markets that's true about
they losing money on a negative interest
rate bond of course you can still use
them for collateral and if all the
central banks are captured as they are
and you can invest in a carry trade
where you're going to end up with a
positive carry because you essentially
have owned all the central banks and the
central banks are private corporations
they're not government institutions you
know you can see how people would be
abusing that market now admit you were
right however about the fact that you
can't taper a Ponzi scheme as the Fed
tried it and then the Fed lost trying to
do it after cutting its balance sheet by
eight percent for the first three
quarters the Fed ended up the year up
two percent on the on the balance sheet
meaning the Fed is now in the money
printing spree not that the rest of the
world never stopped printing money but
the Fed actually put some lip service to
tapering the Ponzi for a few months they
failed they went right back into money
printing so yeah I would assume your
thought there is that that's only going
to continue our interest rates and
you've got the millennial generation
that are trading now you've got all the
up and coming generations that are
trading but they don't understand the
function of interest rates delineate how
much risk your investment should be so
if you have an interest rate that
assumes that the credit risk is zero and
you have junk trade is where triple-a
use between so the markets are totally
distorted in every every possible aspect
I've never seen it I mean years ago 15
or 20 years ago somebody had suggested
this to me I'd say you need to be put
the straitjacket for the well now the
problem it's not because we've got
hundreds of trillions of dollars
negative moving death
it's that's not maybe building that loan
interest rate debt it's out there
it just keeps increasing increasing
increasing so the reason why interest
rates around the way there it's
September of year lows because if they
go up companies will have all this debt
won't be able to service the debt so the
interest will be higher than the revenue
streams coming in which will precipitate
the Fox and once you have defaults it's
gonna be like a dominant I get that
whole scenario which we've been talking
about for four or five years I mean
while the deals get keep getting bigger
and bigger so if you have a half a
trillion or one trillion dollar hostile
rate
that'll perpetuate this Ponzi scheme and
less equity out there to be investing in
and the scarcity value of equity goes up
because all of it's becoming private
equity and we and I think we're just
about out of time but Mitch Firestein
we're gonna keep you over for a second
segment because we love to pick your
brain and find out what your inserts are
thanks for being on the Kaiser report
won't Smacks look forward to the next
session and that's gonna do it for this
edition of Kaiser report with me max
Kaiser and Stacy Herbert like to thank
our guest Mitch fire sign of planet
Ponzi calm you just want to reach us on
twitter it's Kaiser report until next
time bye y'all
[Music]